alors pour mieux se connaître on va voir
ce que vous avez fait dans la vie ce que
vous avez pas fait on va faire une
interview fait ou à faire qu'est-ce qui
a déjà duré
j'ai dit bon courage alors vous répondez
fait ou à faire une nuit avec de geisha
à faire avant un débat philosophique
avec jean claude van damme a fait un
scrabble avec joey starr a fait une
piqûre avant un combat
enfin fait ouais c'est a fait fait
figure de joker j'avais mal à un genou
mamadou kane question va vérifier un la
faire sauter la licence ou en u z une
chaussette dans votre short pour
impressionner les fans à faire vous
faire casser la gueule par un mec d'un
mètre soixante déjà fait déjà fait
je tombe à pic à l'écossé comme ça c'est
d'affilée des français nous servons les
couilles eu cure acceptez de vous
coucher pour de l'argent robert rappelle
toi non je propose une menace pas jeter
l'épongé en plein combat
sinon les proches la nature le drame on
va faire encore approché mais y'a plein
de trucs que vous avez à faire alors ça
je vois mes membres cassés ont été jetés
par les pontes de 5 mégas tiff pâmoison
faut pas l'emmerder
non mais j'ai re faut pas l'emmerder ça
s'est passé sur les courts est sûr de ne
rien rater de in a l'habitude abonnez
vous il m'était impossible eux